resuelve el siguiente problema de forma
gráfica aviven hicieron entregas a
domicilio el pasado fin de semana juntos
ganaron 50 dólares y jabi ganó 10
dólares más que ven cuánto ganó cada uno
de ellos establezcamos algunas variables
aquí sea sea a las ganancias de abbey a
es ganancias
de adi
y sabe las ganancias deben
ganancias
deben y nos dan siete información sobre
estas ganancias nos dicen que juntos
ganaron 50 dólares como lo ponemos
matemáticamente bueno matemáticamente
podemos decir que las ganancias de adi a
más las ganancias deben be es igual a 50
las ganancias de ambos sumadas son 50
dólares también nos dicen a viganó 10
dólares más que ven cómo lo ponemos
matemáticamente las ganancias de adi son
igual a las ganancias de ven más 10
dólares
abi ganó 10 dólares más que ven tenemos
aquí un sistema de dos ecuaciones con
dos incógnitas y nos preguntan cuánto
ganó cada uno de ellos cuánto ganó cada
quien y nos piden resolverlo
gráficamente hay varias maneras de
resolver esto pero vamos a hacerlo como
nos lo piden déjame dibujar unos ejes
aquí el problema se resuelve en el
primer cuadrante pues ninguna de las
ganancias puede ser negativa y déjame
definir el eje vertical como el eje de
adi o el eje las ganancias de abbey y el
eje horizontal
lo voy a definir como el eje de ven el
eje las ganancias deben voy a graficar
cada una de estas dos ecuaciones voy a
escribir esta ecuación de la forma
pendiente ordenada para parecer un poco
extraña pero si va a estar en la forma
pendiente ordenada entonces la voy a
describir aquí aa + b es igual a 50
ahora resto de ambos lados entonces le
estamos del lado izquierdo restamos del
lado derecho y del lado izquierdo que
tenemos tenemos que a es igual a menos b
más 50 observa entonces que cuando b es
igual a 0 a es igual a 50 es decir
nuestra intercepción con a normalmente
la llamamos intersección con b es 50
ubicamos la 10 20 30 40 50 aquí la
tenemos sí vengan 20 dólares entonces
xavi tuvo que haber ganado 50 dólares
basados en esta restricción aquí lo
tenemos así que sabemos que este es un
punto en la línea y también sabemos que
la pendiente es menos 1
ve como la he puesto aquí es la variable
independiente y este coeficiente que
corresponde a la pendiente es menos 1
otra manera de ver esto es si a hizo
cero dólares
entonces ve tuvo que hacer 50 dólares
esto lo vemos también de esta ecuación
si no hizo ganancias entonces ven esos
50 dólares entonces tenemos 10 20 30 40
50 así que estas son dos situaciones y
cualquier punto entre ellos va a
satisfacer esta restricción déjame
conectar los puntos y esta recta es
debido a esta restricción debido a que
juntos ganaron 50 dólares consideremos
ahora la segunda a diga no 10 dólares
más que ven es esta ecuación de aquí que
ya está en la forma pendiente ordenada
si ven hizo cero dólares
abi hizo diez dólares aquí lo tenemos
nuestra pendiente es 1 podemos seguir
así si ven hizo 10 dólares aviso 20
dólares si ven hizo 20 dólares aviso 30
dólares si ven hizo bueno ya lo tenemos
ya tenemos la tendencia de la recta e
inclusive aparece ya el punto de
intersección así que de manera visual
practicamos las dos restricciones juntos
gana 250 dólares es esta línea en
magenta a diga no 10 dólares más que ven
es la restricción por esta línea verde y
parece que el punto de intersección
corresponde a ven ganando un 20 dólares
déjame etiquetar esto 10 20 30 así que
el punto de intersección corresponde a
una ganancia de ven de 20 y ali ganando
10 20 30 dólares
abi ganando 30 dólares así que de manera
visual hemos obtenido que a es igual a
30 y ve es igual a 20 verifiquemos esto
veamos que las ganancias que obtuvimos
para viven satisfacen ambas
restricciones así la primera restricción
a viven juntos ganaron 50 dólares 30 más
20 50 se cumplen esta primera
restricción la segunda restricción es
que abrigan 10 dólares más que ven o que
abrigan o lo que gano ven más 10 dólares
aquí lo vemos había está ganando 10
dólares más que ven así que también se
cumple la segunda restricción sólo
tenemos dos restricciones que se cumplen
ambas así es que esta es nuestra
solución a digan a 30 dólares si ven 20